hello everyone we're pleased to have you
join us for cardinal health lab exchange
welcome to today's live broadcast
clinical laboratories go to Washington
I'm Brenda Kelly chem lab birds and I'll
be your moderator for today's webinar
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by cardinal health
Cardinal Health is a fortune 22 company
that improves the cost effectiveness of
healthcare as business behind healthcare
cardinal health helps pharmacies
hospitals and ambulatory surgery centers
clinical laboratories and physician
offices focus on patient care while
reducing costs enhancing an efficiency
and improving quality Cardinal Health
employs more than 34,000 people
worldwide for more information please
visit www m we have a few important
announcements before we begin we've
designed this webcast to be interactive
and we hope you ask questions during the
event you can submit your questions by
typing them in the Q&A box should be
found by clicking on a great green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many of your questions as we
can today you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner slide window
and finally if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation let us know by clicking on
the support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problem for the green Q&A button on the
lower left I'd now like to introduce
today's speaker Thomas Sparkman Tom
Sparkman was named vice president
government relations for the American
clinical laboratory association in March
2013 prior to joining a CLA mr. Sparkman
was a senior lobbyist at a top lobbying
firm in Washington DC representing
biotech and medical device innovators
hospitals and other providers among
others joining the firm in 2008 he
helped build coalitions on and off
Capitol Hill to achieve his clients
legislative and policy goals mr.
Sparkman has also held positions with
the National Association of State
Medicaid directors the National
Association of pain drug stores in
addition to having practiced as a
pharmacist in Northern Virginia for over
10 years he holds a bachelor of pharmacy
from Rutgers University a master's of
Public Policy from Georgetown University
and the juris doctor from American
University and is licensed as a
pharmacist in the Commonwealth of
Virginia and is an associate member of
the Virginia State Bar I'll now turn it
over to Thomas please presentation Thank
You Brenda and thank you for Cardinal
for inviting me to present it's always a
privilege to get to talk to the
laboratory community and and also listen
back to what everyone is interested in
see what topics are most concerned as
Brenda said I work for the American
clinical laboratory Association and just
to tell you a little bit about them were
the premier trade association in
Washington DC advocating on behalf of
clinical laboratories specifically so we
don't represent for instance
physician-owned laboratories rather the
independent laboratories and that
includes the large national labs such as
quest diagnostics and LabCorp more
regional labs such as a key labs to
medical center labs like Mayo Cleveland
Clinic a RUP with the University of Utah
and also esoteric or what I sometimes
call innovator labs such as myriad
genetics in genomic health which have
the very famous bracket tests and as
Brenda said as a pharmacist attorney
with matches and plug policy degree I'm
happy to chat with you about anything
whether it's why we have
employer-sponsored insurance to the
Affordable Care Act constitutionality to
your everyday allergy minutes so before
we get started I'd like to pull the
audience and see where you all come from
and what your greatest concerns are and
I think some polls are going to pop up
on your screen here are the first being
what type of lab laboratory
practice do you have where you're coming
from and then the second question will
be what you view as the number one issue
facing your laboratory or industry okay
so and Tracy if you can share the
results i'm seeing the results for the
first poll showing up on my screen just
give it a second for it all to come
through
appreciate everyone clicking in here
not a lot of some interesting results
here okay so the results of the first
question of what practice we have a
third from hospital laboratories and
then another third from a national
laboratory and then a third and the
other category perhaps we'll find out
more about the other category later and
then as far as number one issue facing
laboratories it's it's surprisingly
dominant in terms of coverage of new
tests as opposed to reimbursement levels
or laboratory oversight or health
information technology or anything else
so that's really impressive and and
understandable as we'll discuss moving
forward so moving on that's just get rid
of these pop-ups here so being a
pharmacist first I always have to start
off with a drug joke and here we have
the cartoon speed bump for the nice
little lady is walking through what each
of her pills are for whether it's for
her back pain or whether it's for her
hip or as she puts it for to help or
forget how much this is costing me and
as much as I'm putting this up here for
a laugh and to the tongue in cheek it's
also very important to me having
practice as a pharmacist at remembering
no matter what I'm doing in health care
or you know up here in Washington in
health policy that is it everything
always comes back to the patient I'm
never going to forget working on a busy
Saturday in a grocery store pharmacy and
a woman we were having trouble with her
insurance and I was asking her questions
and you know she just kind of stopped
talking for a minute and you know kind
of holding back the tears said it out
loud that her husband had just been
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer that
morning and of course anyone who's been
in those kind of moments realizes how
confusing and overwhelming everything
can be and and really at the end of the
day all of us whatever level we work and
operate at we always have to remember
that it just comes down to the people
and the patients and making sure
that they have everything that they need
so stepping back looking at your entire
conference that you've attended over the
past couple days you all have covered a
number of issues whether it's
reimbursement looking at infectious
disease or cancer hearing about
personalized medicine and and maybe what
the nuts in Congress are working on and
and how that might internally affect
your organization but what I'm hoping to
talk about and cover here today is how
you can also make an external impact and
and why that's going to be important for
you both individually and as an
organization and to really bring this
home this is one of the most striking
and important quotes I've run into from
the early 20th century that the absent
are always in the wrong and you can look
at this from two perspectives one if
you're absent it allows your opponents
to tell your story for you and more
importantly tell the story they prefer
and push forward their objectives
neglecting your own and two if you're
not present you can't voice your point
of view and you can't voice the impact
and how policy issue is going to it you
know be detrimental to you your
organization your employees and as we've
discussed your patients so really keep
this in the back of your mind as we go
forward and that gets me to the key
points that I'm going to want you really
to leave this presentation with today
one as I said others are going to be
happy to write your narrative for you
particularly to their advantage to the
picture in healthcare the big picture in
healthcare is evolving weekly monthly
even daily whether it's with Medicare
whether it's with the various state
Medicaid programs private insurers or or
the larger Affordable Care Act debates
the these big picture trends are
evolving about how we deliver health
care overall and that's going to affect
every provider obviously including
clinical laboratories and then third
within clinical laboratories we are
seeing some very critical paradigm
shifts that are happening now we're and
we'll talk about those in a minute but
they're going to be the environment that
laboratories have existed in for the
past 5 10 in some case 30 years is
indubitably going to be different going
forward in the next two to five years
and we'll talk about that more and in
dealing with these big picture trends
and these laboratory specific paradigms
it's going to be critically important
that you commit with your presence and
we'll talk about what that means and
part of what that means is engaging
policymakers and when you engage
policymakers and this can be you know
locally this can be at the state level
this can be with Congress this can be
with the agencies or even at the
presidential executive level you know
and when you do engage it this has to be
consistent and educational you know one
of the things that you'll hear from
congressional staffers is that they only
hear from their constituencies and they
only hear from stakeholders when things
have already gone wrong and you know
everyone's kind of in an airdrop panic
mode you know that you know the sky is
falling the world is going to end
tomorrow and you know we need you
Congress to enact this legislation
immediately and of course at that point
you know whether it's at the staff level
or at the Congressional level they
haven't had the opportunity to educate
themselves on the issues and certainly
not in any way where they can
objectively view what the true
source of the problem is and what a true
solution might be and sometimes you know
they'll rush to a solution and that
solution might end up being a bad
solution but oftentimes they will it's
very easy for them to choose to do
nothing because you know whatever policy
is causing the problem was put in place
for a reason and rather than question an
agency or we reopen statute it is and
especially if there's stakeholder
disagreement it can be just easier for
them to do nothing and then whatever
problem that you would written risen
with them you know is just going to
continue to fester and be harmful to
your organization so getting to this
first point of others writing your
narrative let's look at a couple
examples so in the August actually they
think this might have been ok let's 2014
august of 2014 the Health and Human
Services Office of Inspector General
issued a report as you see here the
cover questionable billing practices and
Medicare Part B clinical laboratory
services the Office of Inspector General
hadn't reached out to laboratories on
this they hadn't really told us that
they were working on something they just
came out with this report which had
approximately 13 metrics by which they
were going to measure whether or not a
particular billing practice was
quote-unquote you know appropriate or
questionable and you know and they made
a big splash they went into the wall
street journal and said oh you know
clinical laboratories are you know
fudging the books and they're costing
Medicare hundreds of millions of dollars
and you know this is really wrong and
you know Congress should do something
about it but when you actually get into
the report and look at the metrics you
find that really they weren't very well
designed to objectively analyze
laboratories the best example of this is
whether or not
the patient address was a hundred and
fifty miles away from either the the
ordering physician or from the clinical
laboratory and you know to be honest if
you think about you know other Medicare
services the best one that comes to mind
is like prescriptions for the painkiller
oxycontin the proximity of the patient
to the doctor and the provider or the
pharmacy in the case of oxycontin would
make a lot of sense you hear a lot of
stories about drug diversion people
traveling between Tennessee and Florida
and Georgia and Alabama traveling
hundreds of miles to get as many pills
as oxycontin as they can and perhaps
they're addicted and they're abusing the
tablets or perhaps they are I'm selling
them because you know I can you know
there is a street value that's something
of the pharmacist you know I had to be
very conscious of but if you think about
that metric 150 miles from the provider
in terms of laboratories it's if you
think about it in terms of laboratories
well a patient specimen routinely
travels very far in comparisons where
the patient's physical addresses because
not every laboratory not every physical
laboratory and certainly not every
laboratory institution as a whole
provides every single test and so it was
a completely and wholly inappropriate
metric for the OIG to call out as
questionable and there were a couple
others that were similar were you know
they decided to discard physician owns
labs in self referral situations which
is an issue that ACA has worked on for a
number of years and you know just
totally exclude that data to not look at
trends in there and further if you
actually look at their own numbers in
the report they looked at the you know
they're they're lumping all the lab
categories together essentially and
weren't breaking out physician office
labs and
independent labs and clinical labs so
you know when we finally got ahold of
the report you know a CLA you know did
engage with OIG to talk about it and
also prevent further reports of this
nature but you know it very much is
already harmful once this is out there
and folks like The Wall Street Journal
are reporting it and again so the second
example I have someone else reading your
narrative is a very recent article that
we saw in the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel
where they painted a very bleak picture
about oversight of laboratories and this
particular article focused on what
appear to be essentially anecdotal cases
of problems either with internal lab
safety procedures in particular single
instances or you know problems with the
analytical validity of laboratory tests
and so and I use this just as an example
of you know folks are happy to write
about something that they think is going
to make a splash or an impact you know
to be crashed sometimes whether it's a
reporter or whether it's a government
it's a instigator there you know
justifying their existence because you
know look I found the bad guy and we
should go after them but you know it
really creates you know reacting to this
it creates the most work and it's it's
the hardest to respond to it because
these are just going to be out there in
perpetuity you know searchable by Google
and you know any new player comes in
they're just going to use something like
this to wave around we've seen these
covers like this also online disease
testing and I'm sure all of you know is
some of the controversy around Lyme
disease and you know we've seen
reporters you know just trying to blame
the laboratory industry writ large we're
really it's an open question in medical
science about whether chronic Lyme
disease exists you know there are
Diagnostics even fda-approved
Diagnostics for people who want to tell
fda fda approved diagnostics for
cute Lyme disease you've got the Western
blot and the the antibody test but you
know they're they're very willing to
paint these extremely broad strokes and
really ultimately do harm to the
industry and discredit to the amazing
professionals that work in these
laboratories for the betterment know
their patients so how do we deal with
this or when do we need to deal with
this so looking at the big picture
trends that we talked about a couple
slides ago we're looking at continued
coverage and reimbursement revered
pressure and as all you indicated it's
the the coverage of the test and I'm
present thinking back to the wording of
it referring to the insurance coverage
of the test whether that's through
Medicare coverage decisions or whether
through private insurance we're seeing
across the board pressure it doesn't
matter whether you're a laboratory
skilled nursing home a long-term acute
care hospital or a regular Hospital
everyone wants to pay simply just pay
less even historically out of CMS we've
seen trends where they would rather
rather than actually looking at the
policy and why you know a clinical test
service is being prescribed it off and
it is they'll just presume there's mal
fence and that the test is overpaid or
the price is too high and that's why
people are ordering it and so they'll
just lop off a double-digit percentage
off of the code and and say problem
fixed you know we've saved Medicare
because we're paying labs less the other
paradigm we're staying out there is
value-based payments this was really big
in the SGR this is sustainable growth
rate repeal and replace in Medicare that
Congress enacted just a few weeks ago
and I believe was covered in one of your
earlier presentations this is getting to
the idea of just not simply paying for
volume anymore but paying for better
health care outcomes you know if I'm
looking at a diabetes patient
are they actually controlling their
sugar are they staying out of their
hospital emergency room are they keeping
all their fingers and toes and their
eyesight as opposed to someone who is
continuing to degrade leading to heart
disease congestive heart failure and all
that sort so trying to get to this idea
of paying for the value instead of just
hanging for volume and it's really a
leap of faith for everyone right because
everyone's volume is very easy to
measure and it's very concrete whether
you're a regulator a pair or whether
you're actually the provider on but
we've seen and you know particularly at
the family physician level that you know
too much focus on volume does ultimately
hurt the patient and so that's what we
are trying to do is move towards value
and this gets to the third point about
we're seeing folks trying to shift
around the risk involved in health care
spending specifically if you look at
proposals you've either seen out of the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services or even proposals out of
Congress what they're trying to do is
get the government essentially reduce
the government's risk profile and it
gets to the volume issue if the
government just says they'll pay for
everything then they're at risk for you
know essentially an unlimited volume
right and you know and that it creates a
great risk of breaking the bank
overburdening the taxpayer and
everything else so that's what leads to
models such as the accountable care
organizations we saw that Affordable
Care Act and other value based models
because they're trying to shift risk
actually to the providers you know
basically saying of the providers it's
up to you to do better with the patient
and if you don't then we're not going to
pay you as well one or even worse
they're going to penalize you and we've
seen examples of that where hospitals
can now get penalized for a bad
readmission rate if the patients are
coming back
with further problems after having an
inpatient stay at the hospital and then
of course what gets me the most excited
about working with clinical labs and I
really don't want and everyone to take
away doom and gloom because there is
excitement there is very exciting
innovation occurring out in healthcare
and specifically in clinical labs this
concept you know even back when I was
back in Farsi school in the 90s you know
you you know you were essentially
looking at you know just singularly
cancer in an organ based mindset whether
it's prostate cancer or breast cancer
but as we progressed over the past 15 20
years and getting getting to my 20-year
anniversary from all this and so taking
a moment on that one but anyway but what
we've seen in the past 15 to 20 years is
that what you know we're breaking out
cancer into subsets it's not just breast
cancer anymore you know it's actually
five at least five different diseases
and and the same with melanoma and
everything so this kind of gets to the
value proposition for laboratories you
know if we're able to more precisely and
more accurately diagnose the disease
then we can more precisely and more
accurately make the decision one duty
treat to when do we treat and three how
do we treat and those are huge questions
when you see everything in the news
about new drugs costing tens of
thousands of dollars and we all know
that chemotherapy across hundreds of
thousands of dollars in every
chemotherapy but many of them you know
if you can make the decision to not have
to spend that money if you can say to a
patient it's like you're ok you're we
can just observe and that's fine we
don't have to spend $300,000 that's
great you know particularly from the
cost side about thinking about it from
the patient's side they don't have to go
through an uncertain treatment they
don't have to risk the adverse events
you know losing their hair through chemo
is one example the exhaustion you know
the bed confinement and and just and
also the burden on the family
caregivers and and that all starts with
better diagnostics and better laboratory
diagnostics and there's real excitement
about what we're seeing in that regard
and so you know and and and that's
really because of you all on the phone
on the webinar and on the phone here
because you're really pushing forward to
try to get this innovation in excess so
zooming in on the laboratory and what
we're seeing really paradigm shifts here
we have the reform of the Medicare
clinical laboratory fee schedule and and
you heard about that a day or two ago if
not both days this was through the
protecting access to Medicare Act that
was enacted and I believe April first
2014 we're going to move from a static
clinic Medicare fee schedule for
clinical laboratory services to one that
quote unquote follows private market
prices and we are eagerly awaiting CMS
to put out their proposed rule as to how
this is going to be implemented
statutorily they were actually supposed
to have that out by June eleventh but
everything tastes June eleventh by june
thirtieth but they don't even have a
proposed rule out yet so they're
certainly not going to have a final rule
by the end of this month and at this
point we're starting leave na CLA as an
organization is met with CMS multiple
times it has continued to bring us up
that we need to know how this is going
to be implemented because we're getting
down to 18 months because the new prices
are supposed to go live january first of
2017 and which means the data collection
really has to happen earlier much
earlier in 2016 so that CMS can crunch
the data publish what the proposed new
prices would be and allow for everyone
to analyze those and comment them and
eventually get to the final prices in
time for January no one wants to be in a
situation where laboratories have too
short of a time to compile the data sea
you make good submissions good data
submissions to CMS and certainly not and
certainly don't want to get caught
surprised on Christmas Eve with new
final prices that are you know could
potentially you know be bad prices shall
we say and then only have seven days to
either implement or respond because that
could just lead to disaster
organizationally and potentially harm
our ability to provide these services to
patients so second we have FDA threats
to regulate laboratory developed test
services as medical devices this has
been one of my primary charges in the
organizationally and really a huge
concern and gets back to you know
sculpting that excitement I was just
talking about in the innovation of
clinical laboratories this basically the
FDA last year proposed that they want to
regulate laboratories as if they were
medical device manufacturers so that
they can start requiring pre-market
approval for any new laboratory tests
and there's various exemptions that
they've tried to build into that
proposal on that sort and really when
you start getting down to it you know
laboratories just aren't medical device
manufacturers and in the laboratory
developed test services that we provide
are not equivalent to the medical to the
ivd test kits that are sold in
interstate commerce and packaged and
manufactured and all that sort so we've
been talking to Congress about the about
our concern with this proposal and both
the House and the Senate are engaged on
the issue and we're continuing to see if
there are potential alternatives to to
what the FDA has proposed so that
laboratories can continue to provide
quality services and also continue to
innovate and get these better more
powerful Diagnostics available to
patients the third is despite I've
mentioned before the with the new
payment models for physician
it's going to be interesting to to see
how these payment models evolve because
laboratories as ancillary providers
might enter basically service agreements
were there not being paid directly by
the insurance provider or by Medicare or
something they're actually receiving
their payment through the intermediary
you know potentially as a physician or a
hospital and that sort I on you know
have any particular concrete examples
but it's something you can conceive
you're going to start getting back to
these concepts about medical homes and
how the Affordable Care Organizations
work and how the laboratory fits in that
and making sure that the patient has
full access to every diagnostic that
they have on so if models like I
continued to roll out or beep codes are
implemented you know it'll be very
important that laboratories are at the
table making sure that this all the
services are available and then
precision medicine is something we've
seen a lot of coverage on because the
President himself has taken notice of
this on which both at the diagnostic
level and at the drug level getting back
to this concept of making sure that the
patient is diagnosed to the individual
patient level as opposed to a
population-based therapy and actually is
getting the appropriate treatment but
the FDA or the NIH from a research
perspective the NIH might not
necessarily be rigged from a regulatory
perspective to you know handle you know
let's say 314 individualized diagnostic
and treatment plans if we're going to do
everyone in the United States we're
certainly over 300 million people at
this point so you know this is just
again the excitement organization so
okay so we have we have the big picture
trends going back a slide and then we've
got the new paradigms so you know what
do you do with this or organizationally
and you
and how do you make the external impact
namely how do labs tell their story I
you know and a couple more comic strips
because after all it's Thursday
afternoon getting to the end of the week
you know yeah not everyone wants to take
drugs for kind of doing a
tongue-in-cheek you know the idea of
like what if you know pharmacy gave free
samples laboratories certainly can't
give free samples per se and most
certainly in the second cartoon we have
a gentleman who appears to have just
about every facial piercing he has but
still really really hates needles and
you know and we in laboratories are
still very much in the business of veiny
puncture and drawing blood so in
addition to that the laboratory
professionals whether it's the
pathologist so the laboratory ins are
certainly one of the less visible
members of a patient's health care team
you know really almost only comparable
to perhaps the anesthesiologists in the
operating room where you know you're not
in a patient you're not going to meet
your pathologist generally speaking
you're not going to meet the laboratory
Anor the geneticist you know they're you
know they're certainly you know call in
counseling opportunities but you know
and you're also not going to see the
laboratory processing in all likelihood
many of these tests your only visual is
you know is where you get your blood
drawn sometimes that's in the physician
office sometimes that's in a collection
center sometimes it's in the nursing
home so this creates a challenge because
it's not you know it's not necessarily a
product that people rush in and really
want like an iPhone or something and it
can even have kind of those negative
connotations so how exactly do you tell
your story and this is where we get to
committing to your presence and there
are various ways to do this you know
there we're going to talk about capitol
hill in a little bit but you know we saw
examples earlier about you know negative
journalist coverage
and you know one way to tell your story
in a positive way and tell it in an
impactful way is to essentially engage
preemptively you know I talked earlier
about you know taking a posture of just
being reactionary you know and in that
case the problem has already occurred
you know there's already a worst case
scenario in front of you and you're in
mitigation mode as opposed to being
proactive so you want to be able to
start pushing up stories and you engage
it all levels you you want to engage the
media you want to engage policymakers
now the examples I have on the Strand
this slide right here are for the most
part actually reactionary but negative
examples of the media so with the Miami
Herald we have a op-ed with penned by
Doug van oort who works for neo genomics
based in florida one of our member labs
and and so the examples you're going to
see in this slide and other slides date
back to 2013 when there was a very
negative proposed reimbursement out of
CMS where they were going to start
bundling resetting prices under the
clinical lab fee schedule based on
prices they had elsewhere in the
hospital outpatient bundles on and it
was one of the from an advocate advocacy
perspective it was one of those great
moments when many forces came together
to turn back at policy which you know to
ruin the end we were actually it'll turn
back that particular policy in 2013
we're returning examples of how we dealt
with it and created our presence in
response so we have member companies who
are pending op-eds and impactful papers
Miami Herald Miami is well known for
having a huge Medicare population so
members of Congress are going to care a
great deal from that community of Miami
about you know what might be in the
Miami Herald's about particular issues
on a top right we joined with a number
of industry other industry stakeholders
to really detritus proposal and you see
in even he's the FDX you see the College
of American Pathologists the Association
for molecular pathology and others on
this and really you know so we were able
to come together on this issue but it
really learned of impossible if in the
if it hadn't been in the first place
that a CLA members and ACA is an
organization weren't already engaged in
a dialogue with these members it's a lot
harder to rev this up if you know if
folks aren't communicating to begin with
because then you have to start from
square one and then the last example we
have here is what we call earned media
where we we have a reporter writing
about the issue which is you know just
you know you have the you know you have
the inserted media so to speak with the
op-eds where we generate the content
that is also working the reporters now
in terms of Congress Congress has many
levers and depending on the issue and
the status it will alter what you're
asking them to do in this particular
slide we have examples of the
congressional letters they were engaged
on that reimbursement campaign back in
2013 we had well over a hundred members
of Congress which might have actually
set the record for a laboratory issue to
write the agency and really decry how
ill advised to the proposed
reimbursement policy was and you know
and really urge the agency to turn it
back and as I said ultimately they did
but in addition to just writing letters
there Congress can also play a more
behind the scene rolls you can urge your
representative to to just simply call
over and inquire of the agency their
rationale to really like okay
a agency you're saying X and that you
want to do why but I need to know all
the basis for why that's happening and
and really put the agency in a position
where they have to react and justify the
reaction and you know of course there
are congressional hearings and then of
course you know actual statutory action
you know passing legislation which you
know can be a little bit more
complicated and maddening but and it can
be viewed as a last resort because
changing laws a big deal but it's
certainly part and parcel of any sort of
engagement strategy and as a mission
that's something we're talking the
committee is about and stakeholders
about particularly on the FDA issue
right now but let's talk about this a
little bit how you all on this webinar
can engage both individually and
organizationally so in this next slide
we actually have a picture here of
chairman fred Upton turing a lab at the
University of Michigan fred Upton from
Michigan is the chair of the
all-powerful Energy and Commerce
Committee which has jurisdiction over
the FDA the NIH even Clea and certain
portions of Medicare and one of the
things that we do at ACA is that we
actively work with our member
laboratories to see if we can get
members of Congress and policymakers to
actually come into their facilities so
that a laboratory is no longer just the
collection point where they're they're
seeing the needle and the blood draw it
it actually becomes they can actually
conceptually visualize it and understand
all the professionals that it takes for
a laboratory to operate and operate
safely and with a high level of quality
to serve their patients and also work
with physicians who are ordering to test
I've had the privilege of Turing going
on two different lab tours
and you know I can't explain the impact
it has later on members of Congress or
congressional staff because you actually
see the pathologist's walking through
the lot in walking through the lab with
either the samples or the slides of the
biopsies and you actually see the the
dark rooms where they're actually you
know going through the slides with their
microscopes and you start to you know it
really get a picture of what's happening
you know it's not just being processed
through some machine or computer
analyzer and then spit back out
magically to your physician you know
they're actually highly trained highly
qualified people that are working these
processes you know of course there is
some level of automation and it's
important for them to see that too but
doing this really makes policies
understand you know there are actual
constituents behind the laboratory and
within the laboratory and how and an
understanding that one they really care
about providing the best service for
patients and to you know a negative
impact on the institution of the
laboratory and how the laboratory can
provide these services is going to also
have a local impact to the community
whether that's the patient community
that the laboratory serves or even the
local community from the perspective of
you know the folks that work in the lab
our employees and you know and they live
in the area and their kids go to the
schools and and and they're buying
groceries at the grocery store and and
mowing their lawns and and doing
everything you know being part of the
economy in the community and it's
inordinately valuable and it's just not
something members of Congress or their
staff are going to think about when all
they know about a lab is they need to
get blood drawn and then they're handed
a lab report by their physician you know
these days some folks email it so it
really puts it in perspective you know
getting these policymakers into your lab
and you know it's a little harder to do
but you can do this at the
agency level 2 over 2 whether we're
talking about state health authorities
like Medicaid or whether we're talking
about CMS so it's a little bit rarer but
it's certainly in the realm of a
possible at an example so there's make
sure I'm covering on my points here so
those are just kind of examples of you
know like how you engage in what type of
activities you're undertaking to engage
there are of course traditional Capitol
Hill meetings where you're coming to
Washington DC and you're actually
meeting with the staff are the members
here in DC and there's also it's
important to remember the District
congressional offices as well for both
members of the House and members of the
Senate because they all have offices and
staff within their states and and their
districts and sometimes when
organizationally as a laboratory that
can be a great place to start because
those folks in those district offices
their charge is to take care of the home
team you know take care of the
constituents and make sure that any
issues they're having or being addressed
and of course that usually you know with
something dealing with Medicare they're
going to have to put that up the chain
of command which gets to the DC staff
but you know they can be the dog with
the bone at the district level to make
sure that your actual member of Congress
in your senator have the information
that might be critical so those are just
examples and you know folks have
questions we can talk more about that so
we reviewed you know the fact that
others will write your narrative for you
if you're not present you know if you're
absent we've talked about some of the
big big picture trends that we're
continuing to see on the horizon and
again you've reviewed some of these and
some of the other presentations during
this conference we've looked at some of
the paradigm shifts that are affecting
the laboratory community and we've
talked about you know ways to use your
presence whether it's with the media or
with policymakers and you know in social
media
don't forget social media because you
know that's a great way to especially
with the positive messages you know if
you're innovating new tests you know
advertise why that's valuable and social
media is a great way to do it and to
celebrate it and even engage the patient
community you know and they're likely
rules around that that I can't get into
but but it's just another avenue and
we're only seeing more of that social
media engagement whether it's Twitter
whether it's Facebook Instagram what
have you so with all those thoughts in
mind brings me to my second quote here
from the famous Jack Welch from General
Electric you know change before you have
to we're seeing these incredible shifts
in healthcare and and some really
potentially incredible shifts with
laboratory specifically and so it's and
the way you know you change and stay
ahead of all these things is engaging in
talks like today in this conference over
the past 2-3 days because if you get
caught on the wrong side of this you
know that's really going to harm your
institution your employees and Ennis and
as we keep coming back to the patients
that you ultimately serve and so my
thinking ahead about where all these
trends are going you can start to adapt
your organization and your approach so
that you can be part of the solution you
know so part of this is adapting to you
know some of the models that are already
out there and another that is you know
how can we innovate you know are you
know you know is it just at the test
level you know like what what are the
tests that we're rolling out and you
know what's the value of those tests
tackle me make the value concrete but
also you know in of innovative ways to
serve the patients you know we're we've
entered an age or you know the lab
results also have to be made directly
available to the patient so you know
what's the best way to do that I don't
know if we know that yet I you know I
think at large we're still considering
that and thinking through that and how
are we going to deal with you know these
coverage decisions you know what's the
better way to go about it you know
because ultimately if you don't
change you end up in some worst-case
scenarios you know putting this next
article up not really to crawl anybody
out more than example you know of you
know basically you know you don't want
to end up on the wrong side of a
government an investigation you know
this is one recent example where a
laboratory had to pay out I think around
48 million dollars in fines and actually
just this week announced that they were
declaring bankruptcy and I think you
know no matter you know what the facts
of a particular case are you know that's
a bad outcome you know that that's an
organization in a potential organization
not adapting in that proactive way to
best serve patients but again I want to
come back to this point of you know we
absolutely need to be excited about the
future and the reason why I'm excited
about the future is because of folks
like you in the laboratories and just
what the incredible genomic science that
we've seen over the past 15 years you
know these two slides are from hill
briefing and I intended a couple weeks
ago where we had Columbia and mayo we're
presenting and really talking about
these amazing innovations you know it it
is staggering to me to see the chart of
how the cost of sequencing the genome
has gone down so radically and you know
how we can make this information more
usable for both the physician and the
patient and what it's going to take you
know I mean big data you know I feel you
know some labs believe it are doing a
great job of employing big data and
there are these questions whether from
the precision medicine initiative or
other places of how we continue to and
continue to better leverage the big data
to have better health care outcomes and
you know and the amazing thing is you
know these answers are going to come
from you all they're not going to come
from me I just have the privilege of
bragging about them to folks up here in
Washington DC and you
and I love having those stories so you
know definitely you know continue the
good good work that you're all doing
because it yeah obviously it makes my
job easier it's so just kind of in with
that so that brings me to the end of my
presentation and you know and I'm happy
to feel questions there's my contact
information right there and you know and
very again appreciate the opportunity to
speak to you thank you brenda and thank
you cardinal and again you know don't
feel constrained to the subject in the
slide i'm happy to speak about anything
more specifically I just recognize that
on I believe on the last presenter so I
didn't want to get too technical in any
of the slides and of course if I don't
have the answer we can you can reach out
to me individually and I can help find
the answer as well so Brenda Tracy thank
you all right thank you for that
informative presentation and guarantee
happy have you here as part of them
cardinal health exchange I just wanna
remind our audience absolute questions
it's done through being green Q&A button
which can be found in the lower left in
the presentation window and what's
really get to the days we can we do have
a question for you Tom gingin I
printable help system and what is being
done about the CMS interpretation of the
personnel regulations concerning Company
C assessment in a lab performing high
complexity testing they have cats and
tjc requiring someone who meets
technical consultants to assess moderate
complexity tests in a high complexity
lab even though there is no technical
consultant listed for a lab performing
high complexity testing they are
allowing MLG to assess high complexity
testing but not moderate in high
complexity lab so Brenda is it easier
for me to type an answer or to answer
verbally verbally is probably best
everybody can hear you
okay all right so I'm actually going to
admit that this particular issue hasn't
bubbled up to me as yet but it is you
know it's certainly something that we
can take a look at and ginger if you
want to reach out for me individually
via my email address or others I can you
know check with folks in our
organization and see if they know
anything more specifically about it
right out of the gate I restiveness of
that particular issue isn't bubbled up
two months of my level yet okay great we
have another question if someone in the
audience wants to engage policymakers on
these issues what would you suggest as a
first step Johnny feel a bit stupid jerk
actually so really the most important
question is you need to answer the
question what level do you want to be
engaged and make a difference because
depending on who you are and where
you're engaged you can make the decision
about do I want to engage on the
individual level you know literally just
as a voter in the United States you know
who it wants to talk to my congressman
or as a pathologist for an example you
know and in thinking as a pathologist of
course you know there are no there
there's the AMA and other membership
societies that cater to the individual
level if you want to you know get
involved at the organization level at
the institutional level you know then
it's important that you're working with
your leadership team to make sure that
that strategy works within your
organization is it and and deciding how
your organization wants to get involved
you know perhaps it is you know joining
a trade association is a selfish example
you know because you know individually
you can you know redress your grievances
with your congressman but
organizationally there can be broader
benefits
you know from you know given whatever
organization you might choose to join
whether that's at the reimbursement and
coverage level or you know
implementation levels so that it's not
just you know shall we say that the
c-suite that are the individual that's
getting the benefit but all levels of
the organization that gets the benefit
because there are those multiple levels
and multiple time windows to engage you
know there's you know there's when the
statute is working through Congress
there's when the implementation is
occurring there's when the modifications
occur and there's when you actually have
to make it work internally at the
organization and your engagement in your
president's house with all of those and
making that decision about what level
you want to get engaged at whether it's
just simply individually and at that you
know so kind of medical healthcare
professional level or you know or
whether you think you want to mobilize
the organization so that they can all
get the benefit payments it's an
important question to to ask first
before you know trying to pick any of
the steps any of the other steps or
problems that I discussed great thank
you for that answer tom I think that's
all we have now I would like to thank
our sponsors Cardinal Health for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October of
this year you'll receive an email from
lab herbs alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues might have missed
today's wider than gas event again thank
you Tom sparkman for your informative
presentation and thank you to Cardinal
Health for sponsoring this presentation
we hope to see you next time thanks and
goodbye